Speaker 1: OK.
The latest development in the Joe Rogan Spotify
controversy is that the CEO of the Trump affiliated
right wing social media platform Rumble has
offered Rogan 100 million dollars to leave
Spotify and to bring his show to Rumble.
There's a very short and straightforward Reuters
report about this.
Rogan gets $100 million offer from Trump affiliated
site Rumble Rumble Inc, a YouTube style website
popular among U.S. conservatives, has offered
Joe Rogan $100 million over four years for
all his shows.
Days after the podcaster apologized for using
racial slurs in his content, Rogan is facing
backlash for COVID misinformation on his program
hosted on Spotify.
Neil Young and Joni Mitchell pulled their
content from the platform.
The incidents prompted Spotify to add a content
advisory to any episode featuring discussion
of COVID, as scientists and medical professionals
urged the platform to prevent Rogan from spreading
falsehoods.
So the CEO wrote to Rogan.
Chris Pavlovsky is the CEO of Rumble and wrote,
Dear Joe, we stand with you, your guests and
your legion of fans and desire for real conversation.
So we'd like to offer you 100 million reasons
to make the world a better place.
How about you bring all your shows to rumble
both old and new with no sense censorship
for 100 million bucks over four years?
This is our chance to save the world.
And yes, this is totally legit.
So there's a couple different things here
I think that that are important to talk about.
First and foremost, there's a reality that
more than likely Joe Rogan can't just do this
because he's under contract with Spotify.
If Spotify pulled his show, they'd probably
still have to pay him.
Even if they released him from the contract,
they might still have to give him something
if he had some other thing.
You know, we don't know the exact details
of the contract, so it's like an offer Rumble
can make.
That's very unlikely to become a real thing
because of how these contracts tend to work,
and I say that without actually having looked
at Joe Rogan's contract.
But my my concern here is as follows, and
many of you know that no one I've been on
Rogan's program twice.
And when I was on, no topic was off limits
and I said whatever I wanted to.
And Rogan seemed completely open to listening
to what I had to say and in a serious, you
know, and genuine way.
And since then, I have not held back at criticizing
Joe Rogan when he has engaged in spreading
COVID disinformation, either through things
he says or things his guests say that remain
unchallenged.
We lampooned his bizarre interview with Jordan
Peterson.
Like I've, I've not held back at all.
I know that some of my progressive cohort,
some have some parts, elements of my progressive
cohort have held back and I don't know why
it might be.
They don't want to maybe lose future access
to Rogan.
Like, as I've said, he may have no idea about
the things I've been saying, and he might
have me back on if I said, Hey, I'm going
to be down in Austin and I'd love to be on,
or he might never speak to me again.
I have no idea.
I've not exchanged any messages with Rogan
for a while.
I just call it like, I see it.
And on the recent stuff.
I do think that the things that are being
uncovered that Rogan said are absolutely horrible
and disgusting.
And I also believe that his apology was sincere
to the extent that I don't believe that deep
down, he is trying to spread disinformation.
I think he gets lulled into it through something
that we might call kind of like audience capture
and guest capture the circle that he's in.
And it's like, you know, there's people who
are going to say, this is too harsh a critique
and people who will say, I'm being too easy
on Rogan.
I think the reality is that while Rogan has
shown himself to be significantly open minded
for a long time, Rogan is in a circle that
is very culturally conservative, and that
culturally conservative circle includes race.
Race based jokes that I find completely gross
and it it.
It also includes certain ideology when it
comes to government regulation and COVID and
the like.
I mean, the guy has said he has seen the wacky
Texas governor, Greg Abbott, personally since
he has moved to Texas.
Abbott's completely out of his mind and Rogan
from what I've heard acts like.
Greg Abbott is a reasonable normal person
to be listening to listening to.
So there's both the audience of Rogan skews
culturally conservative, and in addition to
that, he's in these culturally conservative
circles, which makes it so that he has more
right wing guess than left wing guys.
Now there's a list that has been spreading
of Rogan's right wing guests versus left wing,
and the right wing list is much longer.
The right wing list is much longer.
At the same time, there were some notable
people missing from the left wing guests that
he has had on me.
For example, I wasn't on that list.
I've been on twice.
So I think with all of these.
No one thing really tells us everything about
this story.
But the real concern I have is he's already
in a sort of right wing echo chamber because
he has gone to Texas and he's hanging out
with Greg Abbott and all these other people
because he is getting the most positive feedback
from the right wing who says his racial comments
are perfectly fine.
His COVID comments are perfectly fine.
And so the concern is it's only going to get
worse.
And I think it's unlikely that Spotify is
going to drop him at this point in time.
And from a very practical perspective, one
of the worst things I can imagine is the show
just getting more right wing that that seems
like it would be a bad thing.
So that's my general perspective on this at
this point in time.
The things that that Rogan has said are completely
indefensible, and he doesn't seem to be defending
them.
And there is question as to whether the apology
is sincere or not.
I mean, of course, that question could sort
of always be asked.
But at this point, the worst thing given the
size of his podcast is for it to become more
of a right wing echo chamber.
He should be held to what he said he would
do, which is to have more people on with views
based on the accepted science on COVID and
and he should be held to that period end of
story.